welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel
okay all
let me know if this audio is okay
because
you guys already know if you've been
here for a minute
i haven't had issues since god knows how
long
but hold on i realize i want to grab my
phone hold on i'm going to wait for you
guys to come on one sec
[Music]
um okay
i want to make sure that i'm live
sometimes it doesn't work
oh yeah it is working okay can you guys
hear me okay
i'm gonna try the sound and make sure
that
um oh i was looking up tables
um
okay let's
i'm just gonna click something random
and see if i can hear it
oh my god i can't
no
oh this is why
oh but i still can't hear it
okay let me try something else
can you guys hear it
can you guys let me see
oh you guys
can it looks like but why can't i
um
okay what about now
weird so this is mike
three volume
no volume
huh
just weird
you can't hear the video okay let's
let's try this
ass
this is why i haven't done reactions in
a minute because i've been having like
tech issues
as usual anyone who's been following me
for a while knows that
you can see firsthand oh here we go
default to
oh you know what what the problem is
are you saying my voice is too loud okay
i can turn it down tell me now does that
sound better
um
uh here we go
the warriors win or i still can't hear
it how weird is this
okay let's see
ten for national championships it seems
year after year hi everybody i'm dan
shulman here
i played that
okay let me try something else
i've been trying to reset this up so i
can do reactions here and there
but
but i know but i can't hear it now
because i know some people missed in
cleveland we've got a sims a little bit
okay
oh my god this doesn't go long enough
okay
star-studded game out on the court among
the interesting i can't hear at it
either
uh is it because let me try
[Music]
oh
you know what
i wonder if that's why
you try flipping this [ __ ]
hold up let's try something
oh i think it's gotta be like
on both sides to make these headphones
work
because that goes there
i don't think it's gonna
work these great high school talents
all right guys i'm going to end the
stream because this is not working
[Music]
video has sound i know but i can't hear
it in my headphones that's my issue
wait let me try one more thing one more
thing if this doesn't work
okay let's try this okay
if this doesn't work then i'm quitting
um
okay let's try this now
desktop audio
[Music]
i'm gonna go to headphones just so this
matches
we got a lot of announcements i can hear
it now i can hear it
could you guys hear me
could you hear it
also how big do we want this
like this is this big enough
cause i gotta look this way
alright tell me if you guys can hear the
video sound
their perspective on this game as well
as i turn first to my right we bring in
dick vitale of course synonymous with
our college basketball coverage tell us
okay cool i got it last minute look at
that
look at that okay what
what should i youtube what do you guys
want me to react to i'll do kevin
samuel's latest video
oh wait
oh i'm gonna watch this actually the
sham booty one i think the problem that
we have with talk
let's do this okay
i'm gonna read the chat on my phone
let me know if the audio visual is cool
okay
talking about sex a lot is that we have
two different energies we have sex and
it's playful it's lusty it's exciting
it's wet it's curious it's fun it's
awkward but in a funny way and then we
talk about sex and it's filled with
insecurities and ego and it's stiff and
it's competitive and it's dry right
she'll probably be shocked as hell that
i'm sitting down here with you
i'm sure many people would be
michelle i don't know what they are they
haven't been listening
[Music]
you hear ellie walking that's what she
does
[Music]
also guys i'm trying to raise so april
1st i get um
i'm buying some new equipment because
i'm getting paid out on it so april 1st
if you um
if you donate anything before then it's
going towards a new camera i'm at like
50 bucks
of the 500 i'm trying to raise which may
or may not happen if it doesn't i'm
still getting a new camera it's just not
the one i was shooting for but
[Music]
yeah i think the volume for pearl is
still
a little high than the video playing
okay let me try turning it down
um i can turn it down
okay we don't know how to do
relationships because you don't really
know one another we really are not in a
place to where we understand who
you are or who i am
and i think it's fascinating because it
should make life a little bit
interesting now because you get to learn
some new stuff
now if you're a person that doesn't like
to learn if you'd like to be
those are the people who are having the
problems with this whole thing they're
like why y'all talk about relationships
all the time
because if you're going to do something
you should want to be better at it
that's part of the reason why i wanted
to sit down with you because
your content is
where you guys on my side will look for
women years my stats would say it's for
women yeah yeah i can be very clear
about that well yeah i mean and the
thing is
all right
so
what do you think
been you see her giving him the eye look
at that she is
misunderstand or misinterpret
about women and sexuality
i think that men have the number one
thing is that there's a very big
difference in that women don't have
sexual desire or women aren't horny
women don't experience sexual desire and
fantasies the same way that they do and
as a result women are supposed to be the
defenders of monogamy and the protectors
of purity and if she's not then she's
not a good woman whereas a man has the
space to be the gamut of things when it
comes to a sexual person that they can
be overly sexual that they can be this
is like the epitome of women only one
equality when it benefits them
like hold on
it's not sorry i had to crack my neck i
had to the
guys there aren't many double standards
that like don't benefit us i think okay
there's some middle ground here right
because the average age of first
marriage is 27.
and odds are
there aren't many 27 year old virgins
that i know
but
the other end of the spectrum i don't
think we want to be telling women just
go do whatever you want and there's no
consequences like that that's not fair
either um
yeah does that make sense i'm gonna keep
going
the underly sexual i mean maybe that's
not true because an underly sexual man
often of course also will get criticized
but
there's this assumption that men's
sexuality is diverse and each person has
their own story but women's sexuality is
a monolith
well as we were kind of talking before
this begin
listening to my mother and her friends
talk about sex and sexuality i learned
quickly that that wasn't true
then i always referred back in my
college experience when i had a sorority
use my condo my town home
or a lock-in
and i listened to a whole weekend of how
these women were talking about i was
shocked
because if a man likes a woman
my dog is barking let me see if my
sister will take him out
hey can you let ellie out eva
hold on
oh my god eva
all right hold on hold on guys i got up
hold on
hold up hold up
i'm in the middle of the
fine
can you go entertain my life
okay
so all right you can sit here while i
let ellie out all right guys my sister's
gonna fill in for me sit here
sit here
these are the these are the chat you can
sit i'm gonna go let ellie out sit here
sit here
okay watch this video and tell them what
you think
i'm not watching the video why not
okay we'll talk to the chat this is the
chat right there
um if you want to watch the video click
play
yeah so that's the mic
you got it where's the camera oh i see
yeah
i don't see
i'll be back
what's up guys
i'm so confused where hannah has hannah
where is the camera even pointing out
because
what you do is you watch the video the
video is on the screen
so it's pointed yeah oh this is lagging
i see
there we go
oh it's in the bathroom
remember i gave your dog a bath
you know what we can talk about guys we
can talk about how messy hannah is
you never know what i'm talking press
the space bar
she's training
[Music]
what
2.0
what
all right
it's like hey man what happened to an
old girl the less we say the more we
like you
yeah no i'm not gonna lie i'm not into
the hannah stuff
but hannah's a mess guys oh my god he
had this mess
i got here like i don't know three four
days ago and i've been cleaning her
apartment ever since
like i've been doing laundry i've been
wiping out counters i've been
reorganizing cabinets there was honey
spilled in her cabinet
like
what's my sign do you mean like star
sign because i'm in aries which i feel
like makes so much sense for me
damn guys i'm good at this
no i'm not pearl
sorry
wait
let me get like
oh wait
no wait i think that may have messed up
what i was trying to do
wait
all right all right
this whole thing
i don't understand
how hannah does this for a living wait
i was looking for this
i was cleaning
because
no you should seriously see how messy
hannah is it's
astrology bs okay you know what me too
now honestly i don't understand
astrology like a lot of the time like i
i understand what the signs are but i
literally could not tell you [ __ ] about
them
can i swear on here
i don't know
uh scoot the other way
wait maybe
maybe
i'm trying i don't know how this works
move the camera to your right
did i fix it
oh i see i see i see i see
anyway do i see
i can spill tea what do you guys want to
know
like i'm here might as well might as
well
let me just like lock hannah out
no i still don't
maybe i'll just like
okay i don't even need the headphones
because i'm not gonna watch the video
so what if i just
right
oh
i had it i had it i i'm so sorry
all right
okay you know what this is
it's complex to see
yes i am i am planning on studying
psychology next year guys
gonna go to college get get educated
is it gonna be a good field to go into i
don't know will it be successful
you know what guys it'll be fun
um
anybody know what the ghoul is
like has anybody watched sinister
oh my god wait hold on
like the ghoul
you see that
seriously such a good movie i recommend
watching both of them
they're both good separately together i
think that the franchise could have done
better
but i'm still expecting a third
um
i'm from chicago
illinois guys
i'm 17.
my birthday's coming up though like
yeah i think hannah's returned what's up
schizo
better
of course i was talking [ __ ] what else
would i do
because your apartment was a mess you
told them my apartment was messy
for all you know i could have given them
a tour oh my god
um
another psychologist
yeah they were hating on psychology for
a moment there
yeah
wait hold on
you can watch the video
no i think i played two seconds of the
video and then i was done i showed them
the
oh the google why is that
because it's pagoulius
no because sinister is seriously the
best like franchise whatever the movie's
together
but apart
no
guys hannah didn't get milk today after
i asked her to get milk so i couldn't
have tea
i tried making tea with that it was
disgusting
no it's thick milk who drinks thick milk
have you ever seen thick water that's
healthy too doesn't mean i'm gonna drink
it it's thick
[Music]
there's a difference between healthier
and just gross
all right
live
and i feel like you need to change your
picture on
um
you're live
oh i forgot to move it actually
i don't know it's like the automatic
all right
i want to see your face my face
you sure you don't want to watch the
video with me thick water yeah thick
water have you ever seen this
no
sick oh my god
um
the next pearl just pearly things 2.0
these comments are funny
you don't want to watch a video with me
you can do like a sister reaction
red pill is not that interesting to
teenagers
oh i forgot
ellie your mom's a mess
eva your room is the messiest out of all
the siblings i was with you for a year
and when i lived there it was disgusting
you had you had food on the floor
you used to have dishes up there
i would use dishes to like change
this is the ice cream
she has a sound board but it's still
what are you
i'm trying to eat what you
even if you want to be in my life just
say that come on
ellie wants to
people are stupid
and they can't
think
am i eating yogurt
all right should i restart this video
i'm going to restart it
because i want to clip this
you sure come on eva
i think the chat liked you
what'd you say
what'd you say
you should react with me come on it'll
be fun
it'll be like bonding time
okay well yeah i mean and the thing is
all right
so
what do you think
men
misunderstand or misinterpret
about women and sexuality
i think that men have the number one
thing is that there's a very big
difference in that women don't have
sexual desire or women aren't horny
women don't experience sexual desire and
fantasies the same way that they do and
as a result women
look at
what eva
what you need snacks okay
i try not to snack i'm trying to eat
less
i've seen you eat two pieces of toast
with honey on it now you're eating
yogurt after we already had dinner so
you're already snacking i want snacks
okay one we woke up at like three
o'clock today so it was more like
breakfast
one okay two
then have some yogurt
yogurt
there's bread i bought you the bread you
so desperately wanted i ate bread
already okay what
eat some fruit
i got some salmon you can make salmon
okay what about um
i can make the i can make wings again
like the drumsticks
okay i'm giving you food options here
why don't you order food
you can order food on deliveroo give me
the card here i can show you the app
did you is this you
i thought this was my troll
no that one's actually mean
my god
okay why not here do you want grab grab
my wallet
and fill out
what
no you can get food i get food delivered
all the time come here
do you deliver it it's got more options
come here i'll show you the app you just
need to switch the card
like go grab my purse
oh okay okay i don't want to put this
card on camera so go over there
go over there and then this is the
uh this
here
oh my god
do you do you want a mic you might might
as well give you a mic because you won't
shut the f up
might as well here i'll just i'll get
you a mic child
because you seem to just have a lot to
say
well because
here's here's your might go ahead
say what you gotta say i'm saying what i
gotta say
it's like it's like
what does this kid want from me
it's like i say i say do you want to be
in my video she says no
love
you weren't hanging out with me maybe
color
color would be i turned off the color on
my phone
i turned the color off on my phone so
it's less addicting sue me where's your
settings sue me i will
where's my settings switch the cards
no do not turn on i'll turn the i'll
turn it back off when i'm done oh my
gosh
i shouldn't eat during the show okay
what
don't say you're not eating i can see
the bowl of yogurt right in front of you
one anybody that's an og watcher of my
channel knows i always eat during my
streams
there are a few times that i don't the
only time i don't is during the pregame
show and i'm not above it
i absolutely would
pearl is getting a taste of what it's
like to deal with women
hannah your phone's going to die
okay well go get
the charger's in my purse
it's at like 10 percent
oh my goodness
okay i'm gonna watch this video now
there is there anything else i can help
you with any other complaints you want
to file
do you really want me to start that list
i could start a big list for you too
with what that i've been keeping up with
the dishes and the laundry the dish is
in the number one okay you started one
load of laundry i've done like four i've
washed your towels multiple times number
two number two
i could have a long list from last year
when i was home okay but you're not home
and that was
six months ago okay number two my
apartment wasn't even bad i have people
in and out of here three times a week so
you can't wipe down the counter it takes
five minutes i wiped down the counter
they were grimy as [ __ ] okay maybe i'm
not that good at it
but i wipe down the counter
oh my goodness she's just
going
fetch out with just pearly login
what log in
oh
okay
why is that your email to pop happy
don't say it they're gonna send [ __ ] to
it
i don't
i'm not even sure what email i used to
set this account but let's
guess this one
your dog is panting
i don't know my password
don't you just use the same password for
everything
no it kept making me make it harder
[Music]
that's fair
okay i got it
i gotta open the app on my iphone
what year were you born
um 1996.
so why
actually never mind
we sent
a six-digit code to your phone oh can
you go grab my other phone my american
phone
because okay it's a three freaking step
verification
she's so freaking annoying oh my god
she's driving me nuts
it's in my black purse it's right you
passed it it's in the hallway
you see it
also stop pretending to be gabby
me
no the person in my chat they always
troll and pretend to be
[Music]
okay put your face id
um
that this person has your code down
this is so pretty
yeah
i'm
yeah
irritated that i have to remember when
your dog ate your laptop oh yeah that
was the worst day of my life i was so
mad i
literally almost killed ellie
ellie did you eat a laptop once
imagine you raising children
you're quite mean sometimes eva somebody
just commented
how are you going to raise children if
you can't even handle your sister i
can't even handle my sister
i can handle my sister
i just might kill her along the
way um
why aren't they giving me the text the
code
okay
google did not why don't you just order
off of my phone because there's no color
eva okay just order i i don't wanna have
to turn on my whole ass
like pay ten dollars to turn on the plan
just because you're too lazy to order in
color or in black and white
like literally
like you're interrupting my whole stream
they gave us a code
scan your card
all right
okay let's watch the video guys
oh this is a long ass video i might do
mediocre tutorials some reviews
okay we're gonna stop singing
eva
aren't you a singer i thought that was
your thing yeah but i'm good at it
ouch
[Laughter]
[Music]
that one kind of hurt
did it hurt because it was true
okay i thought now i'm confused because
i know how to do my eyebrows damn
my eyebrows are perfect so they don't
have to be done
okay caterpillar and two i do not have
caterpillar eyebrows i don't have
eyebrows
one two why didn't maybe your eyebrows
can we teach you how to do that
yeah i i do sometimes can we teach you
to do it correctly
and then find you a place to like get
them plucked oh my god
um do you want sushi
the sushi here isn't really that good
damn asian
never mind what the [ __ ]
do we swear around here
guys where do i get food oh my god
for someone who didn't want to be on the
stream
technically i'm not on the stream i'm
just trying to get food
chicken
there's kfc here yeah there's a lot of
american restaurants here
curious if they even know what kentucky
is
i said i'd be hot at 150 pounds
i literally think that weight is just a
number because it weight's so stupid
it's just how much the earth like
gravity pulls on you
like go to mars you weigh like
i don't know
different
yeah but some way it's healthy in some
way it's not healthy
yeah but i'm just saying
people use it against other people for
no reason
no i don't think it'd be hot at 150 at
160.
[Music]
150. what you might look ill at 150. i'm
one
i'm 180 right now and that's healthy for
now i can get down to like one my
nutritionist said i should be like
ellie
hannah your dog is licking the table
again
guys hannah's dog licks the table
i guess pearl's dog whatever
i want to be like 160 165. that's my oba
oh that no don't do it the the chipotle
and doba like isn't good here
what
no like like um the chipotle and dough
but it tastes different here like it
does it's not good
i would get
i would get pizza or chicken i think
those are the best things here
but you can order in
or if nando's is still open that's
really good the boba
oh boba i think you said q-doba
what is q-doba you know what q-dope is
chipotle it's like the other version of
chipotle
but it's midnight so all the good places
are probably closed
not
available
pearl is not six foot let's get this
right she's five eleven and a half
still five eleven and a half
so it rounds up to what
six foot
we don't round up
why don't we talk about how you are the
shortest in the family
you're shrimp i simply do not your
little sister is taller than you
once again do not care okay because
actually if i was taller it'd make it
harder to ride horses so
[Music]
double pepperoni
that's too many choices
all right chicken
awesome wings
ellie stop licking the table
i need
color eva
just
i'll pick the food
no no because you're irritating me
are you do you want to pick the food or
not
yeah okay stop complaining about the
color
guys i got attacked
[Music]
i thought mediocre tutorial and some
reviews this dramatic ass video talking
about
he's leaving the manosphere
and then
one day ago this video says woke women
and simps say
men should be able
to play in women's sports
like are you nuts
josh eternal thank you for the su two
dollar super chat
you're the prettiest of pearly things
thank you
thank you
did you
logical males
okay let's
could i twerk
no i'm not twerking
i gotta ask one of my other sisters for
that
she would do it too
[Laughter]
that will not be me
this indecisiveness is what men have to
deal with
who said i'm indecisive what if i've
already made my choice okay what what
did you pick i didn't pick
you know what guys i think my sister
really wants me to hang out with her
um so i'm just going to end this stream
because
because
because clearly
she she wants attention right now rhett
and link
good mythical morning react to that